I wanted to open up a discussion,
open up a dialogue,
I think, on the track wife culture.
And this stems primarily from Founders Ministry
last week had,
or at least posted a video, um,
of a snippet of their content,
of their panel that they did with Ali Best Ducky.
And this is not.
I'm not dissing Ali best Becky,
but I do have some things to say.
So her primary goal was to say that tradwave, um,
content is not biblical womanhood or biblical wifehood,
which is true,
and if she would have just stopped there.
Hundred percent true.
It's not. Oh, it.
They're not always conflated together. Um,
you can be a Christian
and you can be a traditional wife,
but there's also traditional wives
who aren't Christians.
However, she goes into the fact that tradwife aesthetics
are merely just cosplaying,
or at least she insinuated that.
Aesthetics or just cosplaying.
But I would like to say,
like, my life that I post on here
most of the time,
unless it's like
a specific type of content,
is 100% what I am doing throughout the day.
I wear dresses
and I do bake bread quite often
or bake goodies quite often,
and I make content. Um,
revolving that,
she then went on to say that,
you know, your favorite influencer is telling you that
if you don't make sourdough,
you're a bad mom.
Not once has I,
have I ever seen somebody flat out say that
if You don't make sourdough,
then you're a bad mom.
And honestly,
if you are saying that,
that's ridiculous
and you just stop.
It's kind of lumping
the entire niche into one single category,
which I don't think is okay to do.
Other things in the Tradwife movement
that are not necessarily biblical
and could be corrected
absolutely 100%.
But that is with anything.
And it is such a fringe topic to be attacking
at a Founders Ministry thing.
I would like to argue that most Christian women
are not in danger of becoming a traditional wife.
Quite the opposite.
But every other niche has an aesthetic.
And no one else says anything about the other topics
that have aesthetics to them.
Aesthetics are a way of showing beauty,
and it's a way of showing God's beauty
and within the home.
If you want relatable mom content
where women are in messy buns and like
an Adam Sandler outfits,
that's great.
That's out there
and that is available to you.
Um, if you want the more
quote unquote
relatable content,
a lot of beauty in the home
that is so easily overlooked
and is so easily dismissed.
And so a movement like the tribe by movement
who is promoting these feminine beauty aesthetics,
there's nothing inherently wrong with that.
And no one is saying
this is the standard you have to meet.
If someone is making you feel
on social media
as like if they are the creator
and they are making
You feel like you have to live up to their standard.
That is not on the creator.
That is you putting standards on yourself
that are perceived.
And I tell you right now,
if you have that,
ever felt that,
go and ask your husband
what his expectations are of you.
Because I personally
like sharing things I do in my home
as encouragement.
Not ever to be like,
oh, look at me,
I'm superior to you.
That is never, ever,
ever what I wanna get across.
It is just simply to encourage you
in the excellence of the home.
There's so much diversity
between each and every one of our lives.
We each have our own style.
We each have our own aesthetic
within this own aesthetic,
if that makes sense.
And your life does not have to look
like somebody you see on social media
is what happens
is that the mainstream media takes
images of people
and portrays that as the face of the tribe
by movement,
when in reality, it's not.
And that's a media issue
that's not on the content creator.
Anyways, I would love to hear your thoughts,
comments, ideas, um,
about this topic.
And also, if you want to go listen to
the, uh, panel,
I highly recommend doing that as well.